In this lecture, we'll describe
the Framingham Heart Study, one
of the most important
epidemiological studies ever
conducted, and the
underlying analytics that
led to our current understanding
of cardiovascular disease.
To motivate how the study
affected our understanding
of blood pressure today,
we describe the case
of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt, FDR
for short, who was the
President of the United States
from 1933 to 1945.
He was the longest-serving
president of the United States,
and he led the country
during difficult times --
the Great Depression,
and World War II.
He died while President
on April 12, 1945.
Before the presidency, FDR's
blood pressure was 140/100.
Today, healthy blood
pressure is considered
to be less than 120/80.
So therefore, 140/100 is today
considered high blood pressure.
One year before his death, his
blood pressure was 210/120.
Today this is called
hypertensive crisis,
and emergency care is needed.
On the other hand,
FDR's personal physician
said a moderate degree
of atherosclerosis
although no more than
normal for a man of his age.
Two months before his death,
his blood pressure was 260/150,
and the day of his
death was 300/190.
There were early misconceptions
in the first half
of the 20th century
about blood pressure.
High blood pressure, dubbed
essential hypertension,
was considered important to
force blood through arteries,
and it was considered harmful
to lower blood pressure.
Today, of course,
we know better.
In the words of Daniel Levy,
the Framingham Heart Study
director, "today presidential
blood pressure numbers
like FDR's would send the
country's leading doctors
racing down hallways,
whisking the nation's leader
into the cardiac care unit
of Bethesda Naval Hospital."
So how did we learn?
In the late 1940s,
the US government
set out to better understand
cardiovascular disease.
The plan was to track a large
cohort of initially healthy
patients over their lifetimes.
A city was chosen, the city
of Framingham, Massachusetts,
to be the site for the study.
Framingham has an
appropriate size.
It's not too large,
it's not too small.
It has a stable population
that doesn't move too much.
And the doctors and residents
were quite cooperative.
So in 1948, the Framingham
Heart Study started.
The study included 5,209
patients, aged 30 to 59.
Patients were given
a questionnaire
and an examination
every two years.
During this examination,
their physical characteristics
were recorded, their behavioral
characteristics, as well as
test results.
Exams and questions
expanded over time,
but the key in the study
was that the trajectory
of the health of
the patients was
followed during their
entire lifespan.
In this class, we
will build models
using the Framingham data
to predict and prevent
heart disease.